bene tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo setting solo con lo stesso re
nazionale proveremo a fare il champion
uno scherzo non saranno esempio perché
mentre giocavo in live sono passato da
diamante 3 a diamanti e 2 divisione
quattro anni al massimo per il diamante
3 posto gol che non ho fatto
e la prima partita non abbiamo fatto
neanche non è vero ho sbagliato tutto
nella vita mi dispiace mi dissocio anche
l'altro non l'ha fregato mercato occhio
no tranquillo nostro tg non è vero che
vedete addio
allora abbiamo giocato lui dei cani ho
tolto la penne che in tutto questo
perché con questa qua e più controllo la
mia c'è la nostra gente tutto esatte
un'altra auto su racket league non ama
ci sta effettivamente cambia cambia in
realtà e non sembrava affatto una cagata
4 rimediare più porro con lemonia tiro
io dai un mamma mia mia parata la pace
che stavamo sta abbastanza bene solo che
la di fermo è stato bravo allora la
butta in mezzo prova toglierla
forse dovevo andare direttamente in
porta io porca vacca cena perché siamo
più forti quindi è il vantaggio che si
dà ai bimbi bravo esattamente quello di
cui parlo una madonna che mi risucchia
minimi piave sempre malissimo insomma è
bellissimo comunque a 15 euro di vale
tutti
per moretto allora gioca tu allora fallo
tu il video non ho capito sto facendo
niente l'ha regalato il gol ha detto
vedrai facciamo che le regaliamo noi due
classi voglio tutti fare i figli in
partenza tutti spiano un gol così a mr
governo una 2 a 1 per noi è un controllo
tendenti a non è male è però c'è lo fa
vige in nazionale c'è di fare una serie
che ritocca ed è pericolosissimo
padovano sporca ma come ci siano lite a
vicenda eccolo come una colpa non ci
sono occhio bravo occhio oggi che la
potenza fatto mezza passaggio che
avevamo fatto delle azioni bellissime
niente
ma che cos'è questa se l'avete
effettivamente non è proprio il massimo
dovevo andar la realtà però non importa
perché stai facendo dunque dove mai più
piacendo quindi vado io a riaffidati ai
visto che non ti devi fidare
aspetta aspetta aspetta parco lemonia
niente con sono marchi bello però che
erano fidati
sono stato io carletti madonna ma le
vedo siete 76 rimbalzata in modo giusto
in mezzo per la mano dai ma dai
mamma mia ragazza tipa così a giocare
con i pali invece che la porta è bravo
però aspetto è proprio un controllo non
è vero che questa arriva di una mancata
lascia e c'era già un altro pronto
volevo andare in carica ai non male
porca live ad avere una bocca però ce
l'ho bravo la punta e mezza e tiro
guarda non l'ha buttata in mezzo ma noi
giocheremo lo strano perché siete se
dobbiamo fare pressing incredibile
perché sennò non segniamo più bello
incredibile questo è il pressing
incredibile questo il preside poi il
fiori tra 3.4 bev atomiche questa
partita promette che ci saranno almeno
altri due gol ma si sta difendendo
assolutamente no frigge uguale palla in
mezzo occhio bravo la tocco un peccato
peccato volevo toccare la per la porta
ma dai non male però non male non ma
normale bravo mi è piaciuto vai vai vai
baracchi di secondi lo facciamo mai lo
stesso vice e pone già facciamo ciao
ciao di mezzo no basta fatti ma dai ma
dai ma dai
prego tocca terra ti scongiuro non ci
credo non ci credo capoterra voi che
l'arma vincente
oddio no ragazzi veramente se diciamo
questa incredibile c'è stata la cosa non
si sa chi la meriti di meno
e incredibile no è rimasta sul soffitto
forse ci arrivò una roba incredibile ma
devo andare sul turbo no ragazzi
veramente non so che dire stabiliamo una
dei party più assurde
oddio ok va bene con l'arrivo di google
turbo andare tocca la ritocca sicuro
tra qui adesso cosa aveva in mezzo
sicuro aia bravo vai o no
madonna mi sono tolto gravissimo ai
spaccato tutto io vi sono tolto mica
stiamo togliendo è stata la roma adesso
ce la faro io perché sono andato sul
turbo da ben tre ma non mi dissocio da
tutto quello che non ho capito niente di
queste riguarda l'inter aveva senso e
non c'è altro da dire
ovviamente 3 mi ha rimesso di 23 perché
mia madre anche a tenere live and the
next one abbiamo un vincitore torneo e
se pure attenzione el'altro s21 stagione
di striscia di partite ne sono andati
bene veniamo con calma affetto
bravissimi anche per il tocco fatto ei
dove vuoi tirare fratello master o dei
master o guai dove vuoi tirare come vuoi
tirare venire bravo io lo sto tirando
nella serie quando segneranno merapi o
nel deretano ma fa niente
dovevo tirare che sono stefani dov'era
eccolo lo steccone eccolo dove voi cosa
volete segnare ma dove volete segnare
che arriva le famiglie dati là dal muro
insegna attenzione la gente ci crede
funzionando davvero aveva 100 lo si
lascia lo si lasciano 10 si lascia
allora c'è stato un po di vento
no no va bene
togliti ho fatto un casino intanto chi
ancora incredibile spetta di cipro
toccato a lui è bravissimo bravissimo
gravi che signori che il signore bravo
dovrebbe parlare quello che aveva sì ma
va bene giusto che non furono quindi un
po pericolosi ma mamma mia che bel cross
ha fatto quello mamma mia che cosa che
sto vedendo ok bravissimo la tiro non
addirittura tira qualcuno bravo la para
la bara madonna hai fatto un sacco di
gol east ha visti 20 e bellissima
opera ho appena finito di dirlo sta
insegnando ai fatto il 5 gol
io l'ho fatto uno fino a regole
possibile incredibile bellissima
bellissima angolazione d'altro urlando e
anche trasceso l'iperspazio dossena è
stato bellissimo due minuti mai mai mai
mai una teca ti ho io
1 v'abbiamo ragazzo non aveva la casa di
che sfiga l'ho presa store da se
l'avessi presa un pelino più dritta come
ho fatto a non segnare che spiega per sé
nella ritocco non la ritocca lewis casa
un bellissimo tiro lo stesso mi stai che
vi antonino recca e 3 gol c'è che
ammirarli fini oggi bravissimo non si
dice insomma faccio le mille di non
champion oggi basta finita che fa
guardate pazzesco veramente fama ragazzi
oggi sono state partite bellissime ma
soprattutto la prima ad arrivare è la
era veramente bareggiate stesso magari
ventata di dante 33
io sono di vedere quattro il road to
champion isrealo adesso è lì da vera la
mia ragazza non è possibile spero di
arrivare champion e so che sono che
seppe carico continuiamo a registrare
che succede dal senso di fiducia momento
è un mi piace attaccare gli step in
descrizione e noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video ragazzi grazie di aver visto il
video è un bacio
[Musica]